uh-huh in five four three two one what's
up everybody welcome to another episode
of the genius brain podcast podcast baby
baby I'm your host David soul and I'm
your auto host George it's a Kawa baby
now remember this podcast is about
anything and everything and we're here
to accompany you on your everyday grind
sometimes people cry sometimes we're
just [ __ ] [ __ ] around other times
I don't [ __ ] know either way we're
here with you your stupid sons of
[ __ ] every single time I've noticed
there's a lady you make them cry yeah
you new comfortable [ __ ]
therapist you everybody comes in here
and starts crying but that's awesome
we've had a that means we get radial
motions here so there's like one episode
III brought a friend on here and it's
not gonna go up but his like it was too
much but yeah she started opening a bus
stuff that I didn't know about I was
like oh [ __ ] like you sure you want to
put too comfortable I probably not I was
like damn Bri do have these two
microphones here know that this is going
on air I was like yeah I mean we
definitely don't put like rarely any
cuts in this unless we absolutely have
to and I was like I can't I can't put
this out because you're a protector to
protect your house like you look crazy
dude like and her story was a little too
personal
it's like to the point where I was like
mm you you work a regular job like a nut
there's like to personal where it's
uncomfortable to hear it yeah like wait
your daddy raped you that's [ __ ]
crazy like that's some next-level [ __ ]
that I don't want to talk about for me I
could listen to I just more like are you
sure you want to put this out like it's
it's pretty heavy you know and not yeah
like if she if she killed somebody
before or something it's like that's too
much that she had I mean
self-incriminating dude yeah she was
talking about some crazy [ __ ] I was like
yo I can I'm not gonna put this out for
your sake later but because she works a
regular job so when you work a 9 to 5
job and you put your stuff out online
like that it's not a very good look and
makes you look terrible cuz just she was
talking abouts like some some [ __ ] about
her company culture and like private
stuff like that oh the world like you
still worked there [ __ ] oh but it was
like some [ __ ] scandalous [ __ ] oh and
I was like this is some good stuff but I
the day I want you to have a [ __ ] job
with all this [ __ ] that I've said I
don't think I could ever get it a job
either did I mean like the boss is gonna
research some [ __ ] and they're gonna see
me talking about get my ass licked and
[ __ ] and how much I that's not a good
look on career so there's no I can't
fail like I have to do this for the rest
of my life we kind of we kind of [ __ ]
put us in the corner ourselves in the
corner on this one dude like I can't
imagine doing this and then trying to
work a corporate job like what well yeah
what would happen to me I don't know
what to do like I'm I'm stuck like all
the [ __ ] that I confessed everything
everything that I talked about yeah I
read something really poignant recently
they like worse somebody was talking
about how we are in a culture of trying
to be more open and emotional about
certain things and be more positive like
but for example he goes I he was like I
don't understand how that makes sense
well we're saying that people had the
ability to change and become better but
at the same time those same people will
dig something out in your past from 20
years ago and burn you at the cross for
it because yeah I guess well how do you
extend that rhetoric make it so hard for
people to change if they know that no
matter what they do no matter how much
they become better as a human being that
you're still gonna hold this one thing
against them but why would that make
people want to change for the better
just because those people are stupid and
they don't change hmm the people that
are like burning you on the cross and
then they're like like let's say you set
a tweet when you're 14 or whatever right
and then you know you're there like 40
years has passed and they're like human
Mingus is yeah man you don't you haven't
lived life I would hate for somebody to
judge me for who I was like ten years
ago man like ten years ago when I said
when we even that was even before I was
doing YouTube man like I I was not a
very nice person dude like if you guys
think I'm an [ __ ] now you should have
known me when I first came to the city
dude I [ __ ] hate ya I think it
depends on people's idea of human nature
to like do you think people are
inherently like once they're shady are
they like that for the rest of
lives or do the people change the people
learned her lesson turn it around I am a
firm believer of changing and people do
change mm-hmm cuz I've seen it firsthand
not only in myself but with in my
friends and within people that I know
and acquaintances and everyone I've seen
it happen yeah so I mean that was one of
my reasons of why I wanted to be a
psychiatrist and work in the in the in
the jail system because there's no
rehabilitation happening yeah and people
just don't understand cause and effect
and why people do the things that they
do no one thinks they're a bad guy never
no one knows that what they do is wrong
it's always everyone else that's wrong
right yeah yeah so people never do
things knowing that they're shady unless
they're really [ __ ] up yeah which is a
very small percentage even the crooks in
prison think that they're doing the
right thing and it's everybody else
that's wrong yeah like like if I mean I
know a lot of people that were
generational gangsters right so they
couldn't wait to go to jail and and and
help and ensure their parents like like
hey I'm an I'm a man now like that was a
rite of passage for for a lot of like
black males that that I went to high
school with like they're like yeah man
joined you know my dad's gang my grandpa
was in the same like [ __ ] gang or
whatever right and and it's like they
were excited to go to jail for something
because that was their way of being like
oh I'm a man now like I got into like a
five in jail I did this and that and
then like I got out
so they serving time was like going to
boot camp
it's so weird when I look back at it now
and then I kind of see the type of stuff
that we used to gas up and get excited
like yeah people would tell us to sit
really oh that's [ __ ] dope but it's
weird as an adult when I look at it and
they go yeah you know I'm up here I'm
reppin this gang yeah this set whatever
Yatta Yatta yeah yeah and I look at that
I'm like you're poor like you chose to
be poor yeah I feel sad yeah it's I feel
like oh man you live in a different
world
and whatever you buy you're poor it's
like first of all like morally or poor
second of all like you're choosing like
financial instability
choosing to be so broke all the time
simply because you want to rep what like
what are you repping you know they
didn't they didn't choose the thug life
it she's real though dude like I'm lucky
enough to where I had balance in my life
where I saw so much different options
right but then I'm like a lot of the
kids that I went to elementary junior
high high school with you mean you live
in an environment where your
grandparents are straight they were gang
member you know your mom was a gang
member like your you grew up in a crack
house where they're having parties every
[ __ ] day like your world is just
completely different yes like hada and i
look at that and i'm like damn how would
they have broken this cycle because it's
it's almost damn near impossible yo if
you watch some of these like gang videos
on YouTube it's hilarious not hilarious
but it's kind of funny because some of
these older cats like verbally they're
saying these things but they're not
really providing their kids with a
better future simply because they just
don't know how they don't know they
weren't given that opportunity but
they're over here like yo like I'm
reppin this gang I'm banging this or
whatever but for my kids I don't want
that they're smart they're gonna be in
school but as they're saying that it's
it's [ __ ] 12 p.m. on a Monday and
their kid is right next to them yeah
yeah yeah but you know they verbally I
think they want better for their kids
yeah it's like I don't want them to do
this but kids emulate their parents
because they're their heroes so yeah who
are they supposed to follow really
supposed to follow by example and that's
their world right so that's their right
and wrong it's like you know killing a
rival or whatever that's their right and
wrong so the the regular laws just don't
apply to them it's just different rules
of conduct and that's just culture right
like it's just that that that tribes
mentality so if people started looking
at people that way then you you you you
know that like all it is is just a
program the way that we go throughout
this world is everything is like weird
this is a computer and we download
different programs of what's okay in
society what's not okay and it's
reinforced by the people around you
so I'm getting kind of heady about this
but what I'm trying to say is that there
is a there the brighter part of this is
there's a book called like [ __ ]
raising or like resilient children or
some [ __ ] right but there are group of
child soldiers that were rescued
so they grew up and all they knew was
like [ __ ] murder and like the worst
of the worst like growing up they were
fed drugs by warlords so they were
always like their sense of reality was
all [ __ ] up right they would hand them
a k47 and you're talking about like nine
year olds just going out into the field
murdering people their friends are
[ __ ] raping people in the villages
sad [ __ ] right yeah you would think
they're [ __ ] up forever they get a
chance to come to America or they get
rescued by some like I don't know like
some Peace Corps or whatever like one of
these organizations rescue them and then
they go through rehabilitation and they
realize oh [ __ ] there's a different
world out here and I don't have to kill
I don't have to do all these things you
would think that this [ __ ] is
gonna be a psycho killer for the rest of
his life
yeah but they become great members of
society and there's so many studies
where like yet there's trauma and
violence and things that people go
through but people do change and
rehabilitate and there's so many
beautiful things that come out from this
like ability to to be in hell and then
you rise up from it and there are I
think there's a lot of people that don't
believe that that can happen so they
think that once you're tainted once you
did something wrong you're always gonna
be like that for the rest of your life
yeah which I don't think is true yeah
there's the human Cape you mean
capability is really amazing you know
and environment and how people are
taught especially at a young age like
I've seen this growing up my whole life
because so I go you guys already know
this I got room but not a great
neighborhood specifically because my
parents tour wasn't a great neighborhood
it's a part of South Sacramento and
there's some of these kids that and I
think like that I'll be up for their
parents I'm pretty sure they're trying
their best or even if not they there's
this thing like back so if you grow up
in the hood here's some simple [ __ ] some
people would just have kids just because
they want to government is
yeah so that's this is not me just
saying [ __ ] this is like legit some [ __ ]
like because I'm pretty sure that's just
that tribes culture right like so like
someone within their like their mom or
somebody we're like yeah you know what
you need to do is just pop out kids yeah
I don't even know that until like I kept
hearing it over over in the store and
also yeah what the [ __ ] is is and I
there's you get more money for not being
in a relationship like yeah with a
husband so it promotes single mother
yeah yeah and then you get like the
section 8 housing [ __ ] so they're paying
like a hundred bucks for a [ __ ] huge
ass house because they got three kids
and they're a single mom or some [ __ ]
and so like I'm talking about I remember
in the store hearing this girl getting
hyped about she got knocked up she's
like oh she says oh yeah I got pregnant
I got another kid you know that paycheck
that government Patriots gonna come
through that section 8 housing I'm like
you know what the [ __ ] what is this
stuff and then I asked a couple of so
you know a couple of a hairstyles that
come to my parent store and get stuff
they're like you know some sad [ __ ] like
that's what it is they get government
assistance so a lot of these younger
women who don't who just this is like
the neighborhood and their life that
they want to live like this is just what
it is for them yeah you know she goes
it's sad but that's what it is and
that's the first time I ever found out
about that [ __ ] yeah yeah I mean I think
it's kind of [ __ ] up but also it is
everyone's just trying to survive I
think that's what it is right yeah and
you you [ __ ] like if I could pop out
kids and just get paid for it yeah I
wish I can - yeah but if you realize
their world they don't even know that
this [ __ ] exists like what's they don't
understand the possibilities like what
they're personally capable of yeah and
we see it as like oh man you're throwing
your life away girl what are you doing
in but I mean I get it - cuz I grew up
not even realizing college was an option
yeah I should I mean the Asian
stereotype like I don't think I grew up
with the Asian stereotype right like
your people were pushed to their [ __ ]
limits to get good grades and go to
college and I I mean I saw that with
other people but I also saw the other
side where like college was for geniuses
and not for me yeah you know and it
sucks because people they live they all
live in a bubble
so they don't know that other people
don't live in the same [ __ ] bubble so
they it's easy to look at someone and be
like hey man you're wrong because you're
doing things that are immoral it's so
easy to look at them because it's like
I'm over here on this high ground I'm
working hard and you're not yeah
and I think that's the same mentality
people have it's like they try to dig
your [ __ ] Twitter history for the
last twenty years and then they find
some [ __ ] and I'm like look at how
homophobic this guy yeah look at how
look at how racist this [ __ ] is yeah
you know I think people get off they get
off on gained dislike moral night any
like people love taking people down it
makes them feel like I'm the hero in the
story and it's a very it's [ __ ]
pathetic flawed cancel cancel cultures
cancer is mad like that one [ __ ] that
that was like moderate my pop culture is
not your [ __ ] dress you actually dig
further and he's out there using the
n-word and all that stuff and it's like
yeah they pulled that [ __ ] out but you
also cannot you know it's the whole like
he's without sin cast the first stone
[ __ ] you [ __ ] everyone's doing that
same [ __ ] Warren Dave Chappelle's case
he with us he without sin must cast the
first rock and I shall smoke if it hello
everybody this podcast is brought to you
by purple now if Hef you have ever had a
terrible night's sleep I'm talking about
your backs is hurting I'm talking about
the upper backs I'm talking about the
lower backs well guess what I guarantee
you ain't got a purple mattress like I
do because purple mattress my friend
mattresses helps me sleep because it's a
mattress a soft and firm at the same
time I'm talking about this mattress was
developed with technology made for
rocket scientists I'm talking about a
purple mattress my friends that helped
me with my insomnia that helped me get a
better night sleep and I'm telling you
if you haven't had this mattress before
guess what you are missing out this is
gonna be a hundred night risk-free trial
if if my friends you want one if you're
not fully satisfied with it you can
return your mattress for a full refund
backed by a ten year warranty
shipping and returns you're going to
love purple and right now
my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're offering site-wide just
text brain to eight four - eight eight
eight the only way to get this free
pillow is to text brain to eight four -
eight eight eight that's be our AI n -
eight - four - eight eight eight
it's weird like people have this odd
like moral high ground and you know I
think I'm guilty of this too because
when something doesn't rub with me right
morally I'm pretty sure anybody can dig
up something that I say and said like
well you've done this it's very true we
just have strong opinions yeah we have
very strong opinions - and also - when
people say like I'm not a hypocrite
you're [ __ ] lying dude everybody's an
advocate because we it's art it's hard
to look inwards a lot right it's just a
certain way we want we project a lot of
things that we hate that we see in
ourselves so or you're afraid that
people see in you yeah so well yeah talk
man yeah they're like no you're such a
hip you said this in your last house I
probably did you're right Bob I if I've
ever saw one my god you know what I've
been doing recently so is like I'm
trying to create this whole concept of
how deal with like negativity online
right so kind of working on it maybe I
might turn it into a book or something
but so now everybody's online right and
I've been online I actually was a very
early adopter of online culture AOL days
I was like 13 years old
now a lot of people was online yet so
the online bullying online like targeted
bullying by other people like the
harassment hacking into your [ __ ]
calling your house non-stop prank
calling your parents like dating your
account suspended all these like online
tactics that was like the beginning of
it and then like daxing in all this [ __ ]
right yeah and then later like people do
it all the time now an online harassment
but I'm so used to that [ __ ] cuz I
experienced it when I was like 13 or 14
that now it's like once you get
physically jumped and all these other
things
you're just like what are you talking
about but I know you're being harassed
online and how much it [ __ ] me up like
getting my accounts canceled and [ __ ]
like that
yeah and even though the way that it's
done today it's different because today
like you see the person's face you see
like it's very real right you know um
and in so it's like how do people deal
with this new phenomenon like like how
like at least you knew the face of your
bully back then yeah at least your bully
was scary and like you knew that that
[ __ ] was walking your way oh [ __ ]
right and versus now like it can be
someone from Germany and you don't even
know this person but they're just
bullying the [ __ ] out of you or like
first and you don't even know who
they're it's fake accounts it's all
these things how do you deal with not
being able to fight back and there's
like a lot of naivety on my part when it
comes to when I say oh [ __ ] if I have a
kid I want to make sure that they're not
on the social media [ __ ] but it's like
how like there yeah that is the current
standard so am I going to like it yeah I
understand you know trying to control
the amount and how they perceive it and
what they do but to try to take that
away when it's just just social norm and
a standard it's gonna be a very hard I'm
no battle like cuz I don't I don't know
if I can do that right because I don't
like if our parents were like you can't
use the telephone exactly why because
it's bad influence like we need to use
the phone what the [ __ ] else am I
supposed to do I feel like if I if I
take that away from my kids it's what
the [ __ ] are you doing man so the best
way I'm thinking like the best thing I
want to put out there is to create a
something where people can deal with
troll and negativity like synchronize
like target of bullying like you know
all this [ __ ] right there's so many
there's just a whole different world of
online culture and I think it's [ __ ]
with people's heads so far so much
because they can't escape it at least
for us it's like I get anxiety before I
went to school because I knew I was
gonna see this [ __ ] bully mmm but I
but after school finished that's it I'm
home I'm safe but
now these not just kids but adults
everybody as long as you're on Twitter
or Facebook or you could be just
scrolling through whatever and it's like
here's that [ __ ] commenting again man
you're bullying - it's so weird when I
hear people they're like they go I'm
going to stop bullying by 20-somethings
like you'll never stop bullying that is
built into our [ __ ] DNA as animals
like bullying you will never ever ever
stop and one of the and I feel like this
is a really good this is really good
advice to give is instead of trying to
stop bullying which no actually don't
try to stop bullying but for me good
advice is try to understand what you can
control what you can't control
yeah cuz you can't control why this kid
has some kind of [ __ ] up upbringing to
why he has to constantly ridicule you to
make himself feel better yeah but you
could try to do things to prevent that
to make you feel a certain way right and
yeah that was the best way that I
learned how to deal with it because when
I was a kid I was the [ __ ] mind you
man weird-looking [ __ ] kid when I got
bullied I went home I looked in the
mirror said I get it yeah really
I couldn't help it but so what I started
doing and in order to number one how to
cope within it and get better at it is I
learned how to number one stand up for
myself number two I started learning how
to do like self-deprecating humor
because in my mind was like if I already
made fun of myself how can you make fun
of me dude you can't buy my jokes and
myself are better than yours and that
started that started allowing me to cope
with it and eventually that bullying
kind of stopped because it wasn't really
funny anymore
like I'm not the I'm not the butt of the
joke so there was ways for me to learn
how to deal with it outside of putting
that pressure on everybody else to hurry
up and change and leave me alone yeah
it's just because it's not gonna [ __ ]
happen man yeah I mean you're totally
right I think I belong more to this
school of thought where it's like
criminals are always gonna exists you
need to learn self-defense yeah I think
the other school of thought is like we
should all evolve as a society and like
change and I'm like you can't change
human nature but also when they hear
that they hear let's avoid the problem
so it's I think it's just a
communication error because I'm not
avoiding the problem I'm not allowing
that bully
exists I'm just trying to empower people
to deal with bullies yeah versus you
know like people are like well maybe you
got to sit down and talk but yeah we're
all trying to deal with it but in
different ways right like for example
like you can't ever rule out violence
like I think it's it's it's hopeful
thinking like it's it's awesome if we
could we can not ever have violence
mm-hmm but it's human nature you know
and you got to be realistic about it
right it's like if you open up a store
in a bad neighborhood are you gonna get
mad that you got robbed because to me
it's like yes morally you shouldn't have
got robbed but you should know that the
crime rate here is high yeah and you're
statistically vulnerable it's like duh
[ __ ] so yeah it's like when we
were when we were doing this JK news
awhile ago like I remember there was
this article about a girl who number one
went to South America and and when she
went to South America it was she was
already warned about how dangerous the
area that they were staying in was and
for women specifically not to go out at
night yeah right because they were just
rapists every right it is just like but
you shouldn't be raping in the first
place I am a woman I'm gonna [ __ ] do
my thang yeah and if I remember
correctly I think she got kidnapped and
raped yeah and I and you know and this
is this is prior to I think there was
conversations where people say hey say
people shouldn't be raping in the first
no [ __ ] [ __ ] I think we all agree I
think we all agree I mean it's like the
couple that decided that they're not
gonna let their racism or whatever stop
them from biking into Isis territory and
they get [ __ ] murder by Isis yeah and
it's like these people I think are very
I call it like just bubble sheep right
like this that you just have no clue how
dangerous the world really is
to me it's like if you if you decide to
swim piranhas and you get bit is it the
piranhas fault
yeah like sure piranhas shouldn't be
attacking humans but you decided to swim
in that tank and and what why do you
think that you
can change the world in this way it's
almost really selfish hmm and like very
self-righteous to think that you are
Jesus himself you're the exception to
the [ __ ] rule like what's gonna
happen like I just hearing that article
- I remember I was irritated I was like
what the [ __ ] are you thinking dude like
I understand that that the world is
[ __ ] up and it shouldn't be that way
but the fact of the matter is as of
right now yes and you doing that wasn't
gonna evoke the change in that country
in that specific area did not have you
get hurt like it wasn't there for you it
wasn't safe for you what the [ __ ] were
you thinking I'm not happy that happened
to that person that's not what I'm
saying what I'm saying is like dude you
could have made a better choice well a
lot of people hear that and make the
argument like you shouldn't blame the
victim and all these things because I
think it's just a communication errors
that it's like we live in different
worlds right like I think the people
that believe these things they have a
they kind of don't have a realistic idea
of how the world and humans are are so
they might have a more optimistic idea
of this world like if if if there were
no guns then we wouldn't have war or
like they would have this mentality
which is a dope way to think and want to
achieve but realistically they have they
just not they're just not realizing the
amount of work that it takes to get
there and how fast you can get there so
do you think about the whole like
especially because recently they had the
there was there was three shootings
right so actually yeah girl got garlic
festival which was all supposed to go to
Dad's crate and I was actually supposed
to go to that because of Gina's birthday
that we weren't going to go and then
there was the one it was in Texas right
El Paso
El Paso and then Ohio yeah and then if
you see all the killers they all look
like nerdy McLovin no they all look the
[ __ ] same dude with the same glasses
and everything I heard too that yeah I
heard too because they all put out like
the the thing that they had in common
was they put out a manifesto at like
4chan or some [ __ ] like that or a chant
or whatever if I and so he's thinking
about actually
shutting down his forum because of that
because they're using that as a platform
either to gain notoriety or be famous
before they do these things so he's
thinking about shutting that [ __ ] down
which is kind of crazy and I know that
every time this happens that happens
like there's this flare of like gun
control happening gun control and I
don't know anything about gun control in
guns and I don't know what the solution
is because I just don't want to come out
and say like well we're gonna get rid of
all of our guns because if I just think
about it from my layman terms of
knowledge I don't think that's possible
so I'm looking for what is what is the
option that we have - what is the
solution to make this make sure that
this doesn't happen as frequent right
well so okay there's man there's so many
ways to look at this and it's and it's
just like one of those huge like
cultural topics that gets really touchy
because like you know me I'm a gun owner
and I wouldn't call myself a gun rights
advocate but I am very well-informed
about this stuff right because there's a
lot of ways you can look at the whole
gun debate you have one camp and this is
I'll go from the extremes right you have
one camp that believes that we should be
like Japan or Australia or Europe where
we completely do away with this outdated
Second Amendment rule we take out all
the guns and we melt them down just like
what Australia did and we will have no
more you know mass shootings or at least
what we can do is try to change that
right so that's their that's their point
of view um and the opposition to that is
well you know the only people that are
gonna turn in their guns are law-abiding
citizens yeah right and and so all the
drug dealers and criminals and all these
people they're not gonna turn in their
guns cuz all those guns are illegal yeah
right so now all the good citizens who
follow the law they're gonna be unarmed
which is now gonna create like this you
know oh it's a it's it's a [ __ ] free
free for all for all criminals now we
could now we know that we can go rob
these people and like they're not
guns yeah right so that's that's the
other side of the argument to that okay
now there's also like in between where
like some people are like well why do we
have to have these crazy military-grade
guns like why can't we just have like
hunting rifles and make it okay there
which in a lot of control like highly
controlled gun countries like I say like
Canada or whatever like maybe Japan's a
good example is like guns aren't
completely outlawed there but if you
want to go hunt or whatever like there's
a strict way that process that you could
go by doing that and so yeah that that's
one argument or some people that are
like and this is more like on the left
side they'll be like well you shouldn't
you shouldn't have to have like these
high-power things maybe just a handgun
or maybe just this or why do we have to
have these mass killing things right and
so they don't want to limit all they
don't want to take away all the guns but
they do want to limit like what types of
guns hmm and and so and then I would say
the right argument to that would be like
well what if the bad guy has a bigger
gun than me like you limit my ability to
have 30 bullets let's say 10 of these
guys come and I don't I'm not a good
target shooter like I can't get them all
I can only have like 5 bullets and my
gun there's just so many of these like
instances of like well this and in this
it's like abortion it's like all these
topics right it's so [ __ ] hard to
just find a middle ground because of
these reasons and on top of that there's
culture so for example city culture is
completely different from rural culture
yeah right city culture like there's
really no need for a gun unless for
self-protection or whatever like you're
not out there hunting every day you're
not doing all these other stuff but farm
culture you don't you you know a lot of
people kind of have to be the police for
each other like your neighbor might be
like 30 miles away or whatever right and
everyone kind of watches out for each
other and what are you gonna do when all
these coyotes come
you gotta like [ __ ] protect your
livestock or what's happening in New
Mexico and Arizona is you have like the
drug drug cartel like kind of coming
through and crossing the border with
like [ __ ] massive guns and SUVs and
things like that they're running down
these little towns out on the border no
one knows about that so that's like one
of the reasons why people just want to
secure that area because the police
force there isn't strong enough and I
know this also because I know a violent
ear police officer he goes out there and
he does community service like so you
could be a part-time cop in areas that
really need their help right and he says
that even though there's a lot of
volunteer police officers that would
come and help out like they have to do
this hush-hush thing with the drug
cartels because they're like well we
could either cause a lot of problems in
your town or just let us pass by and
he's like I [ __ ] hate that mmm-hmm
but there's just for some reason like
not enough manpower and not enough staff
and not enough money and not enough
everything so what the citizens want to
do is like they want to arm themselves
and feel protected it's literally the
Wild West out there it's like a
third-world country people don't know
that this [ __ ] exists in America because
we're out here in the city we're out
here in in in areas that are kind of
there's a police like right right down
the street or whatever like we feel safe
that's the thing I think about a lot too
like when I go to like North Carolina or
some kind of [ __ ] honky tonk town and
I'm like if I got murdered right now
nobody would know for at least a month
exactly like nobody would [ __ ] how would
you know my house is in the middle of a
[ __ ] forest how the [ __ ] would you
know somebody killed me yeah so that's
why you would you would see these that's
why they're more Republican and all that
and they're like man you you [ __ ]
Democrats are trying to take my guns
away I would feel the same way too and
it's like it's so easy to tell them why
don't you learn how to code and [ __ ]
move to Silicon Valley just get the [ __ ]
out of there but it's hard to leave your
roots like where you were born
with your friends your family everything
in if you guys live in a rural area in
their tight-knit communities there
they're like a family within a family
you know what is what is the you know
what the proposed ideas are for better
gun control so what what is a step to
get a gun now like it's it's it's
dependent on the state okay so so it's
not reversal no no well there's there's
there's like people that are trying to
push a universal background check yeah
so like California has more of the
strict laws ten days you have to after
you apply it's a ten day background
check it goes straight to the state they
see if you have any prior convictions
they see if you have any felonies and/or
like Violent Crimes or if anyone has a
restraining order on you if you've
recently you know been diagnosed with
any mental disorders stuff like that
yeah and then they just want ten days
because what a lot of people do is like
back in a day to just buy a gun and
[ __ ] kill themselves yeah so they
they want you to kind of take that time
make sure you're not acting [ __ ]
crazy yeah so you get you so there's a
tenday background check and then
afterwards like you you basically what's
the word yeah you get your gun if you
clear and yeah and it's 18 for rifles uh
21 for handguns because that's the
problem like I just you know when you
know people always try to ask I don't
know why you guys ask youtubers about
this [ __ ] unless like people unless the
youtuber knows what the [ __ ] they're
talking about I'm you know when there's
like subjects when it comes to politics
or even something like gun control I
don't [ __ ] know I don't know like
they're like well can you put up this
thing to take away guns for everybody
I'm like I don't know what that solution
is because it's funny because you
mention that [ __ ] where you're like cuz
I haven't really read up too much about
the stuff but I did think about that I
did think about okay so you're asking
people who have registered guns to give
up their weapons Yeah right okay fine
what about the people who don't have
registered guns it's like then I get
scared now now I'm scared
right because
that one thing that I had for protection
and then you put it out there for
everybody to know every [ __ ] criminal
to know ya said every citizen in this
world in the United States will not have
a gun to protect them that scares me
that scares the [ __ ] out of me yo cuz
y'all [ __ ] if I say I don't
have a gun who's the who's to say I
don't or I do you don't know ya muhfucka
shoot you in the face like I don't know
about that [ __ ] I mean Neil deGrasse
Tyson just posted something right right
right after the shootings right and man
this is such a touch touchy subject
because I hate [ __ ] mass shooters I
hate that the gun is used in this manner
with towards civilians and things like
that right and for me like it's it's not
an it's not very I I need to be
emotional but sometimes I'm too much of
a macro thinker
so and I think Neil deGrasse Tyson did
the same thing where he was like hey
guys like every time something happens
take a step back and not dive into
emotional things and then he was like so
you know within the last year like 800
people died from the flu 300 people died
from this and he just came and listed
there's a lot of things that because
there's this meme that was going around
with all the different flags of how many
mass shootings it's a zero and then
America has like 250 or whatever right
so someone as genius as him he was
getting so much [ __ ] ridicule because
I get it like you can't talk about this
stuff because people are so pissed like
and and they don't want to hear anything
and they're just like why do we live in
a world where there are people coming
out and shooting others for no reason
and all this stuff and I it's it's a
tough thing to talk about especially if
you're a gun owner and then you believe
that people should be armed because now
people are like well what all these
people are just gonna be like the Old
West shooting each other I get that too
because I don't trust everybody with
guns mm-hmm
I think some people are
we [ __ ] morons and they don't train
and they don't they're not even prepared
to do it so but it's difficult because
that's the world we live in and that's
the society that we in kind of inherited
right mm-hmm so I personally think it's
a cultural issue my my my whole take on
this is okay so during our parents
generation
yeah I'm their kids or whatever right
you can mail order guns they didn't have
this mass shooting phenomenon is our
generation thing guns were so available
like remember when we did that a sailing
trip with that Native Hawaiian right and
remember how he was like when we were
kids we would just walk around with our
rifles on this we would shoot pigs down
and when we got the [ __ ] pig we would
take it to the liquor store and then
they would give us candy yeah so they
walked around with rifles bro like and
and like well Jessa's dad was saying
like yeah when we would be driving
around and we see some like pheasant or
whatever we would just pull over real
quick ball shoot them and then out on
the regular interstate yeah everything
was just know people were walking around
like this is a fishing pool or whatever
like it wasn't like oh no this guy's
gonna [ __ ] kill me like people
weren't pointing it at each other on a
daily basis so what I think is there
social decay and I think this is this is
what a lot of I guess a Republican
talking point or whatever but one of the
things that they want to focus more on
is is what's going on with American
families that that's driving these young
people to go out so violently and
wanting to shoot and go crazy like
what's happening to our families hmm
what's what's happening there that's
that's making this happen you know which
I also believe in is like maybe you got
to do a bunch of things right like
because the solution the solution seems
so simple and when I hear a simple
solution yeah I automatically think it's
not going to work this is not a simple
solution as nothing in this world that
I've learned you know has ever been that
simple for somebody to come out and say
like my people people know I'm actually
scared of guns you know so
I'm not neither here or there on things
right so for me as somebody who's an
outsider who's just looking at it I just
I don't know what the viable solution is
because I don't know anybody who's
bringing up a solution that's of sound
mind it's just you here or it's too
there so it's difficult there's there's
something there you know what I mean and
I don't know if there's if I don't know
who that leader is that could really
help us figure out what that's going to
be because right now it's what I hear is
get rid of every single gun and to me
that's asinine because it's not possible
I mean there's 800 million guns in the
u.s. you're how is that gonna happen
you're not going to do that so let's
take that off the table because it's not
realistic let's not say [ __ ]
unrealistic things right yeah and and
also it's just ingrained into the
American culture of if you do that then
you're gonna get a lot of people that is
gonna turn on the government because one
of the one of the reasons why there are
gun owners too is not for the fact of
hunting or any other things but there's
a lot of people that believe that that
is how you keep our government scared
now I'm not a part of that belief camp
but I'm just saying that there is a
group of people that that think it's
there it's it's their American duty just
as much as voting just as much as all
these things to buy a gun and to keep
the government in check yeah so and also
I not on the other side of things to
like I also find it really stupid like
with people's like connections to their
guns are a little bit extreme like
they're like you taking away my gun is
you tell me I can't be American it's
like all right bro yeah I mean yeah it's
it's a very emotional topic man yeah so
whether you talk to the right or the
left it's very [ __ ] irrational and
emotional and it can go really bad
because no one's listening to each other
and for me ultimately it's there's a
there's a fine balance to everything and
it's difficult to to apply one law with
a whole country of people with different
value systems like so so though the law
that applies to a city dweller it's not
gonna be the same law that applies to
some farmer hmm for sure yeah yeah cuz I
did think about that too like I said
just out in the middle of nowhere I'm
done because I don't I
know when by the time I call a cop how
fast I don't I'm scared of that now and
I live in a city yeah like when some
[ __ ] goes down I'm not thinking if I
call the cops they'll be here in the
next 30 [ __ ] seconds yeah somebody
tries to break down my door I'm gonna
[ __ ] shoot them right because whom
I'm basically I am expecting the best
result in a situation where the best
result result rarely happens Yeah right
because I think when people when people
kind of grow up in a nice neighborhood
they don't realize yeah when you call a
cop they don't come immediately yeah
even though I've been told by people
I've had this debate right they're like
why don't you use a bat why don't you
learn martial arts
why don't you do this I'm like okay I'm
a five foot seven dude
that's about a hundred and fifty hundred
sixty pounds right like I could only do
so much there's six feet guys out there
multiple guys out there and then even
meeting there's there's women that are
510 with a hundred and four ten with
with a hundred pounds right like what
are they gonna do yeah what you know and
it just sucks that we do live in this
world but you don't understand the
threats that can happen hey everybody
this podcast is brought to you by away
the thoughtful luggage for modern travel
now personally I love away luggages
number one it's actually the thing that
I use when I travel a lot so you guys
already know or if you don't know I'm
actually on a traveling food show right
now so the oh wait luggage has been my
luggage that I carry on with me
everywhere that I go number one it's
very simple the wheels on it are great
they glide like a mofo and on top of
that I love the way it's designed I mean
you can get it in multiple colors I
personally like the sleek black one that
I have it's very inconspicuous and what
I like about it the most my friends is
the fact that it works with my style so
the one that I have actually has an
injectable battery so you guys know when
you travel you're on your phone
sometimes you have lay overs well guess
what
in the back of the bigger carry-on that
I had there is an injectable battery and
I use that to charge my phone or
whatever I have that needs a quick
charge
or for example I have wireless earbuds
so with my wireless earbuds die well not
to worry I have an injectable battery in
the back that I always go to so if you
don't have the bigger carry on you can
get the regular carry on which is also
lightweight very durable
there's a hundred day trial that allows
you to use these products and if you
don't like it you can return it or
whatever you like a limited lifetime
warranty they'll fix or replace your
back if it ever gets damaged a built in
compression pad which helps you pack
more and there's just a lot more
features on these bags so remember guys
a hundred day trial on everything away
makes take it on the road and live with
it travel with it get lost with it if
you decide it's not for you you can
return any non personalized item for a
full refund no ifs ands or asterisk buts
so check it out guys so for our genius
brain listeners for $20 off a suitcase
visit away travel calm / genius brain
and use the promo code genius brain
during checkout once again for $20 off a
suitcase visit away travel calm / genius
brain they use promo code genius brain
that's one word genius brain during the
checkout to get $20 off do we have a
friend recently that got his house
broken into and robbed by like three
dudes and he was fortunate enough that
he wasn't there
yeah and he lives in a very nice [ __ ]
neighborhood you don't know these type
of things and they only recently caught
these guys after they raided and broke
into like three or four people's home
yeah and it took like four or five
houses to get raided for them to finally
get caught yep and that's the type of
[ __ ] that freaks me out because if I was
in that house I would have shot that
[ __ ] in a [ __ ] instant yeah I
mean and that's what I mean by like a
lot of blind sheep they there the other
side of the argument that they don't
understand that this stuff exists it
happens it one online yeah we have cop
friends - yo I'm talking about I have a
cop buddy that tells me he goes I was
like well how many crimes do you think
it basically came up to a topic because
there's a guy that flipped out and he
started stabbing people at this Carl's
jr. right and I was like oh how come
that wasn't on the news he goes why
would we put that what they won't be on
the news because [ __ ] like that happens
in LA everyday everyday and something
I'm zafo 'king day so the stuff that you
see on the news he goes that's just the
amount that they can cover and they can
choose which is bigger than the other he
goes that type of [ __ ] happens so often
you have no idea how many times I have
to go in for somebody getting stabbed
shot robbed beaten almost dam death
every [ __ ] day in the city because
you just don't hear about just cuz you
don't hear about it doesn't mean it
doesn't happen and that's the part that
freaks me out that he was so it looks
like yep it happened because that
actually happened yesterday to out of
other burking I'm like the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is going on and it's crazy dude
it's just it sucks but that's the world
we live in you know yeah and and it's
like I I mean I believe in self-defense
and I believe that I'm gonna exercise my
right if I can have I'm going to do it
Stephanie we're wrapping up this podcast
let me let me call you in like 30
seconds
that's okay let me black yeah that's
definitely she's gonna be on the next
pot yeah but I mean it's a touchy
subject I'm all you know a lot of people
are also afraid to talk about this stuff
especially in entertainment especially
in LA being such a liberal state I'm
always down to talk about it yeah
because you know like I'm okay with
being hated and I it's not if I talk
about it doesn't mean that I like mass
shootings I [ __ ] hate math I hate
people who use it I hate criminals yeah
I don't want them to [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] I think when when we speak about
thought right people people kind of just
get entrenched in their own views and
they want to think the worst out of you
because it affects them personally on a
personal level so yeah for me I like
conversation and I want people to talk
about so I can understand so just
because somebody when people here I see
it all the time to go you're pro-gun you
like [ __ ] murders like yeah take a
flutter Utah how did you get there they
take it so far
like I'll say a few things that might
sound Republican and all of a sudden I'm
an all right [ __ ] I say a few
things that sound liberal and it's like
dude there's just two different schools
of thought that I kind of agree with
some points on both sides and and and
they are the leading force of certain
thoughts so I'm just who else am I gonna
[ __ ] quote you know like it's it's
like on the gun debate there's two
schools of thoughts
there's this [ __ ] funny thing where I
was on a plane and there was like
straight up I'm talking about Mexican
homie this dude look Mexican is [ __ ]
like I'm talking about as Mexican as
Mexican you get in LA and this fool had
to make make America great again like
hat right you see everyone that planes
like super [ __ ] uncomfortable looking
at him and then I started laughing right
yeah and then people like why are you
laughing I was like he's doing his best
to make sure he's not gonna get deported
you understand I think that's his ploy
to be like nobody's thinking me for bro
you look Mexican as [ __ ] I was like damn
dawg I don't think you guys realize this
is like the smartest thing he's doing
right now he's like nobody's [ __ ]
taking me today as a minor side make
America great again right [ __ ] Mexican
people right well guys that wraps up
this episode of the James brain podcast
yo let's let's spark that conversation
man because I know I'm interested too so
in the comments I want to see if you
guys have a solution that might be well
and I thought of the things that I hear
are from people that don't really
research the history looks a lot they
even miss identify like and categorize
the gun so it's like if you're gonna
talk about cars know your car yeah
you're gonna talk about guns know your
guns so same thing because I want to
have discussions and and I want to read
in the comments
different viewpoints because maybe
there's something that I missed maybe
there's something that I didn't really
think through yeah a lot of the talking
points I've seen in red but I still want
to know more yeah don't be [ __ ] mad
when you do it either just [ __ ] talk
you stupid sons of [ __ ] they could be
bad I don't care see us on a Spotify
podcast any type of podcast platforms
out there we're talking about iTunes if
you're on there give us that five star
say what's up I love you very much your
mom kisses me so sweet at night she has
soft lips [ __ ] you guys I love you very
much
peace she smelled like a mothball